QUESTIONS.
IT'S RHETORICAL.
RAISE YOUR HAND IF YOU THINK WE
SHOULD HAVE GONE.
>> THIS IMAGE OF AN AMERICAN
PRESIDENT?
THAT'S WHY I'VE BEEN SAYING
SOMEBODY SO WEAK AND FRAIL AND A
COGNITIVE MESS.
AMERICA DESERVES BETTER.
WE DON'T LEAVE OUR FELLOW
CITIZENS, OUR FELLOW AMERICANS
BEHIND.
WE RESCUE OUR FELLOW MILES PER
HOURS TRAPPED BEHIND ENEMY
LINES.
WE RESPOND TO TERROR ATTACKS
WITH OVERWHELMING FORCE.
WE HAVE THE GREATEST MILITARY ON
THE FORCE OF THE EARTH.
WE STRIKE FEAR INTO THE HEARTS
OF ALL OF OUR ENEMIES AND
INSTILL CONFIDENCE IN ALL OF OUR
ALLIES.
UNDER BIDEN, NONE OF THAT HAS
HAPPENED AND CLEARLY WILL
HAPPEN.
MADE THAT CLEAR YESTERDAY.
THE ONE THING THAT WAS CLEAR.
NO MORE MILITARY PRESENCE.
WE'RE GETTING OUT.
STICKING TO THE TIMETABLE AND
YEAH, THERE WILL BE AMERICANS
LEFT BEHIND IN ALL LIKELIHOOD.
NOW WE'RE SUFFERING THE
CONSEQUENCES OF HIS REAL
WEAKNESSES IN REAL TIME.
MARK MY WORDS, WITH SO MANY
TRAPPED, THIS COULD ALL GET SO
MUCH WORSE BEFORE IT GETS
BETTER.
I PRAY THAT I AM WRONG.
OUR FIRST GUEST TONIGHT, IT
COMES FROM THE -- TO THE U.S.
FROM NORTHERN AFGHANISTAN, HIS
BOSS, IS SO-CALLED PRESIDENT OF
AFGHANISTAN REPORTEDLY FLED THE
COUNTRY MANY WEEKS AGO WITH FOUR
CARS AND A HELICOPTER FULL OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF CASH.
MY NEXT GUEST IS THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF AFGHANISTAN, STILL
IN THE COUNTRY, LEADING THE
RESISTANCE AGAINST THE TALIBAN.
TONIGHT HE'S PLEDGING TO HELP
ANY AMERICANS THAT WILL BE LEFT
BEHIND.
YOU'RE IN THE NORTHERN PART OF
AFGHANISTAN.
I UNDERSTAND YOU HAVE A VERY
STRONG RESISTANCE GROWING BY THE
DAY.
I HAVE REPORTS ON THE GROUND
THAT I HAVE CONFIRMED THAT
YOU'RE LEADING THE COUNTRY, THE
DEFACTOR RESISTANCE OF THE
COUNTRY AND THE RIGHTFUL PLACE
CONSIDERS YOUR PRESIDENT LEFT.
MY QUESTION IS, WHAT WOULD YOU
NEED TO ENSURE THE SAFETY OF OUR
AFGHAN ALLIES, INNOCENT AFGHAN
CITIZENS AND AMERICANS THAT WILL
BE LEFT BEHIND?
BECAUSE I WANT MY FELLOW
AMERICANS BROUGHT HOME SAFELY.
>> WELL, WE NEED TWO TO THREE
THINGS TO BE DONE AND THESE ARE
DOABLE THINGS AND SAVE THE LIVES
OF AMERICANS AND MOST LIKELY
SAVE THE LIVES OF MILLIONS OF
AFGHANS.
NUMBER 1, PAKISTANI TALIBAN AND
AL-QUAIDA ARE CELEBRATING DEFEAT
OF THE UNITED STATES.
IT'S A MESS FOR JOE BIDEN'S
ADMINISTRATION TO TAKE PAKISTANI
ISIS.
THAT'S NUMBER 1.
NUMBER 2, THEY SHOULD MAKE IT
VERY CLEAR TO THE TALIBAN NOW IN
CONTROL OF KABUL THAT IF ONE
MORE ATTACK IS CARRIED OUT, IT
WILL BE TALIBAN RESPONSIBLE FOR
IT BECAUSE FEW DAYS BACK, WE
WARNED THE AMERICANS THAT THE
ONLY WAY FOR TALIBAN TO GAIN
CONTROL OF THE KABUL AIRPORT IS
TO STAGE SUICIDE ATTACKS OR
ATTACKS AND BLAME IT ON ISIS.
OTHERWISE, THIS FIASCO WON'T END
SOON.
SO FOR TALIBAN TO SAY IT'S NOT
TALIBAN OR THE CREATOR OF THE
SUICIDE BOMBING IN AFGHANISTAN
OVER THE PAST 20 YEARS, THEY
CANNOT BECOME INNOCENT
OVERNIGHT.
NUMBER 3, UNITED STATES MUST USE
THEIR POWER OF CONVENING AND
POWER OF BRINGING NATIONS
TOGETHER TO CREATE ALLIANCE FOR
PEACE AFTER THEY CREATED AN
ALLIANCE FOR WAR AGAINST
TERRORISM.
THEY SHOULD NOT ABANDON
AFGHANISTAN.
THERE'S A LOT THE UNITED STATES
CAN DO.
TODAY THE AFGHANS, EVERYBODY
WATCHING, THE SUPER POWER
SEAMING SO WEAK.
THAT SHOULD BE AVERTED.
THESE ARE DOABLE THINGS.
WE'RE NOT ASKING YOU TO
REESCALATE, COME BACK
MILITARILY.
WE'RE ASKING THE UNITED STATES
TO PROJECT HOPE, POWER.
NOT WEAKNESS, NOT A SUPER POWER
ON THE RUN AND UNABLE TO DO
ANYTHING.
THE UNITED STATES --
>> Sean: LET ME EXPLAIN
SOMETHING TO YOU --
>> THIS IS UNITED STATES IS
DEFEATED.
THIS IS A DISASTER.
>> Sean: YOU NEED TO UNDERSTAND
SOMETHING.
THE UNITED STATES UNDER THIS
PRESIDENT, NOT THE LAST
PRESIDENT, UNDER THIS PRESIDENT,
HAS NO APPETITE TO PROVIDE ANY
ASSISTANCE AT THIS POINT.
YESTERDAY AT THE PRESS
CONFERENCE, JOE BIDEN WAS VERY
CLEAR, HE HAS NO APPETITE TO
SEND TROOPS IN EVEN TO SAVE
AMERICANS AND LEAVING THE
PROSPECT OF AMERICANS BEHIND.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT THE VAST
OVERWHELMING MASSIVE MAJORITY OF
AMERICANS FIND THAT REPULSIVE,
SIR.
WITH THAT SAID, I DON'T CONTROL
THE PRESIDENT, I DON'T CONTROL
CONGRESS.
WE'RE GOING TO BRING IN A
SENATOR AND A CONGRESSMAN IN A
MINUTE.
MY QUESTION TO YOU IS
SPECIFICALLY, CAN YOU TELL US
HOW MUCH FIGHTERS YOU HAVE, WHAT
KIND OF EQUIPMENT YOU HAVE, WHAT
ARE THE THINGS THAT AMERICA
MIGHT BE OFFER TO OFFER YOU
MILITARILY SO YOU CAN ACCOMPLISH
YOUR MISSION OF DEFEATING THE
TALIBAN, ISIS-K, THE EMERGENCE
OF AL-QUAIDA AND HELP AMERICANS
IN THE PROCESS THAT MIGHT BE
LEFT BEHIND GET HOME?
>> FIRST OF ALL, IF ANY AMERICAN
TRIES TO TAKE SAFE HARBOR THAT
WE CREATED, WE WILL PROVIDE THEM
PROTECTION AND MAKE SURE THAT
THEY ARE SAFE AND WE WILL
COORDINATE WHATEVER WAY POSSIBLE
SO THESE AMERICANS WILL BE
EVACUATED.
SO THE VALLEY TODAY IS NOT ONLY
A VALLEY.
IT'S A CENTER AND A SAFE HAVEN
AND THE CAPITOL FOR ALL OF THOSE
THAT FEAR THEIR LIVES, THAT ARE
FEARING TALIBAN TERRORISTS AND
TRYING TO GET TO SOMEWHERE TO
FEEL SAFE.
SO WITH THAT SAID, WHAT IS OUR
STRENGTH?
THE BIGGEST STRENGTH WE HAVE IS
OUR POLITICAL WILL.
WHICH UNFORTUNATELY ISN'T THERE
IN WASHINGTON.
THE UNITED STATES IS CAPABLE OF
DOING EVERYTHING.
BUT THE DECISION WHICH WAS TAKEN
TO WITHDRAW TROOPS FROM
AFGHANISTAN SO ABRUPTLY WAS A
POLITICAL DECISION.
IT HAS HURT THE FEELINGS OF SO
MANY AMERICAN SERVICE MEMBERS,
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY,
STRATEGIC COMMUNITY.
I UNDERSTAND WASHINGTON WAS
FATIGUED BY PAYING BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS AND RETAPING THE TROOPS
IN AFGHANISTAN.
WHAT YOU'RE SEEING NOW, AMERICA
IS PAYING WITH ITS REPUTATION
AN